a world war ii veteran who later became
a hero of the pandemic
is being laid to rest this morning in
england captain tom
moore died from the coronavirus earlier
this month at the age of
100. charlie dagetta is in london where
a nation is saying goodbye
good morning well humbled to the end
captain sir tom
once said it would be quite a joke to
look down on his funeral
and chuckle at everyone making a fuss of
him and touching to think that
complete strangers might weep over his
passing
[Music]
a royal air force flyby is usually the
reserve of royalty
heads of state war heroes but then
world war ii veteran captain sir tom
moore became a war hero of sorts in the
last year of his life
captain tom captured the hearts of this
nation and the world last year
with one small gesture walk a hundred
laps of his garden
to mark his 100th birthday raise some
money from battled workers of britain's
national health service
he ended up raising more than 40 million
dollars
earning among other accolades a
knighthood from the queen
the last time i spoke with captain tom
we talked about a movie deal in the
works
is the world ready for captain tom the
movie
that's a very good question though he
wasn't quite ready for hollywood's walk
of fame
just yet whatever the result i don't
anticipate ever
coming into into america i'm
putting my hand in a piece of work
concrete somewhere
sadly one of very few moments sir
captain tom
didn't live to see in an epilogue to his
book
writing about his inevitable passing
captain tom wrote
life will go on babies will be bored
and people will eventually forget about
captain tom
he added for a while though i'll be
remembered for the last years of my life
rather than those that went before a
rare blessing he said he only wants
a little white headstone to mark his
existence
in his words nothing too fancy
for cbs this morning saturday charlie
dagetta
bedford england we love that we love
cats
yeah i hope we remember him far longer
oh yeah and the song that keeps ringing
in my head
ground control to major time but captain
tom
it's all yours now